so it's not just the areas of the white
house or the media or corporate america
or even the law where the left feels its
oats they feel ascendant but the
backlash is coming it's in the area of
culture they're going
way way too far in the culture so for
example marvel
for some ungodly reason for some reason
that no one can comprehend
decided that it would be a wonderful
idea to have ta-nehisi coates write
captain america comics this makes no
sense at all
captain america's character is a
character who was frozen
in the 1940s and then reanimated
years and years later he's supposed to
be a refugee from
1940s america ra rob that's why he's
captain america
right he's supposed to stand for all of
the values of the united states
among them are not america is a deeply
racist country
plagued by by by structural
injustices america's rooted in evil and
racism and cruelty
so to have somebody write captain
america you might want to pick somebody
who actually likes the country
who likes the declaration of
independence and the constitution
somebody who doesn't think america is
evil from its inception you know
somebody who doesn't think like the 6019
project but no
marvel decided it was not good enough to
have tan hassi coates write the black
panther comics
he had to also write the captain america
comics which is nuts okay ta-nehisi
coates is a person
who said in an interview with the with
with the new yorker i believe
he said that on 9 11 he sat on the top
of his brooklyn
apartment building slightly stoned
watched 911 happen watched the planes go
into the buildings and people throwing
themselves from the 80th story of the
world trade center
down to their deaths watched the towers
collapse and felt nothing
that's how much he hates the country
tane hassi codes right that is something
he said openly and
that was considered okay because after
all there's been racial evil in america
and ta-nehisi coates who's gotten
extraordinarily wealthy and
extraordinarily famous by talking about
how terrible america is he should write
the captain america comment
and comic so on its face this is an
absurdity it's interesting it's like
having noam chomsky right superman right
truth justice in the american way except
that america is an imperialist invader
that is constantly destroying countries
around the world yeah get no arm to
write it makes for noam chomsky should
write
superman ta-nehisi quotes writing
captain america is the same thing so
it's stupid on its face
but it's not just stupid what they
actually allowed tanahasi coats to do
here
is portray red skull who's the villain
in the
captain america and people say why do
you even bother talking about the
culture because
more people in america engage with the
culture than engage in politics
culture is important culture is upstream
of politics and when you start
mainstreaming
complete and utter nasty and slanderous
bull crap
about not only the country but about
anybody who disagrees with you into
discourse that is meant mainly for
teenagers you know what you get a worse
country they're gonna push too hard here
they really are so tana hussey coats
put out this comic the comic shows red
skull
recruiting people online uh you know
where this is going don't you
recruiting recruiting people online red
skull right who's a nazi
right red skull as a character is a nazi
who had his face burned off and he's
like and he's now a mutant and elves
okay and here is the panel it says the
red skull
it is a picture of the red skull on a
laptop
and it says 10 rules for life next to
his face
who do you think that's supposed to be
10 rules for life
could that possibly be jordan peterson
just to reiterate the point just to make
sure that you know it's supposed to be
jordan peterson
it then says in the corner chaos and
order
because of course jordan's books are all
about
leading a finding order within the chaos
right these are terms that jordan
frequently uses and he talks about
feminism and so just to make sure it
says the feminist
trap right the feminist trap so you're
supposed to know that this is
in fact the that this is in fact jordan
peterson
and not only that he he then has a
reference
to carl lugar who of course is a is a
deeply famous anti-semite
viewed as sort of a model for nazism in
the pre-nazi era
he's sort of the proto-nazi so the idea
is that jordan is a nazi
hey that's absurd on its face it's
absurd it's slanderous
honest to god it's it's it's disgusting
because ta-nehisi codes is just a damned
liar
so i know jordan i've read pretty much
everything jordan's written
i've watched many of his videos as you
have i'm sure the notion that he is
pro-nazi is insane it is insipid and it
is ridiculous
but the red skull is a nazi and is
actually jordan peterson in this comic
directed toward teenagers and then
there's this other conversation that
happens about how red skull is
recruiting people
in in which captain america says it's
the same for all of them
young men weak looking for purpose i
found the flag
you found the badge they found the skull
he tells them what they've always longed
to hear that they are secretly great
that the whole world is against them
that if they're truly men they'll fight
back
and bingo that's their purpose that's
what they live for and that's what
they'll die for so if you tell
young men that they have a purpose in
the world if you try to tell young men
not to pity themselves and be losers if
you tell them to make their bed
this is this makes you a nazi like red
skull tanahasi quotes writing that
in a comic book our culture the wokeness
and comics by the way has been going on
for a long time
dc did this too dc tried to make
superman into an anti-police figure
they had a batman comic in which batman
was railing against
the cops not just the corrupt gotham
city cops or like cops generally and
about racial injustice and all this kind
of stuff
marvel has now trotted out a gay teen
captain america and i was like this is
this is not a surprise but to have
ta-nehisi coates
mainlining all this crap into like the
captain america comic does tell you
something about where our culture is
and our entire cultural infrastructure
has been taken over by people who are
completely removed from the everyday
lives of the people with whom they are
supposed to be talking
because your typical comic consumer is
not somebody who believes that jordan
peterson is the red skull
just like your typical consumer of
television is not somebody who believes
that we should be
spending our days fretting over how to
turn girls into boys and boys into girls
when they are young people
when they are tiny and yet this is the
direction in which our culture is moving
by the way there are some soft-hearted
republicans and i shouldn't say
soft-hearted soft-headed because they're
not soft-hearted
in fact what they're promoting here is
really not soft-tarted soft-headed
republicans asa hutchinson
the governor of arkansas comes to mind
he was thoroughly shellacked by tucker
carlson
last night on his show as he should have
been because he decided that he was
going to veto a bill which was then
overridden by the arkansas legislature
the bill prohibited the use of
transgender
on children below the age of 17 i
believe
and he vetoed that and he said well you
know we shouldn't be getting government
involved in these areas
oh you mean protecting children from the
destruction of their bodies
by by pseudo-medical professionals
who don't know the first thing about
what they're talking about and are
simply following woke precepts with
regard to gender
in any case our culture has been
promoting that that's that's why we
ended up in this situation
so you have sophia bush who says that
you know we are
that we that if you don't allow child
sex changes that is talent amount to
murder
sophia bush tweeted out voting rights
are under attack the gop has launched
over 250
voter suppression bills just a lie
they're trying to kill democracy it's
the new jim crow
it's against all we stand for okay
that's lie number one put that to the
side because the left is always
promoting the lie that republicans are
engaged in voter suppression
even though that is obviously not true
then she tweeted out
trans kids are under attack across the
country ar just banned them from
accessing health care this is tantamount
to murder
kids will tell us who they are it's our
job to support them not demonize or harm
them
um okay first of all the baseline notion
that kids will tell you who they are is
the biggest
load of crap i have ever heard in my
life i have three children
all under the age of eight if my
four-year-old tells me
he is a robot guess what he is not a
robot you know what it would make me
if i said okay you're a robot it would
make me a deeply irresponsible and
moronic parent
it is your job to civilize your child it
is not your child your
child's job to proclaim their authentic
self to you at four and for you to take
everything that they say super seriously
because that's idiotic you are smarter
than a four-year-old and if you're not
you shouldn't be a parent but beyond
that this is just a lie
she says that arkansas banned trans kids
from accessing healthcare no
arkansas banned trans arkansas bans all
children
from being experimented on by doctors
using
hormone therapies to block puberty and
mutilate their bodies
that's what arkansas just banned but
don't worry if you watch our culture
this is not just opposition this is the
position it's a position that is
parroted by the entire mainstream media
which uses the exact same phraseology
with regard to the arkansas bill the
idea is
that if you as a state don't allow
doctors to practice
medical chicanery on children that if
you don't allow doctors
to mutilate children with hormone
therapy again you don't know the
long-term cost of using puberty blockers
on an eight-year-old
that if you do this then this somehow
makes you a murderer
a murderer whereas presumably you're a
better person
if you say a seven-year-old is gender
confused because we keep preaching to
them in public school that they might be
a member of the opposite sex and they
don't know what that means because it
doesn't make any internal sense
and also they don't know what it means
because they are children so number one
if you're an adult you shouldn't know
what it means because it makes no sense
if you're a child you certainly
shouldn't know what it means because
you're stupid and it makes no sense
and yet the idea here from our entire
media and from our entire cultural
sphere
is that if you stand in the way of this
that you are somehow the bad guy the
backlash to this is going to happen it
is going to be tremendous
there will be a backlash to all of this
there'll be a backlash to the
corresponding of our culture
i mean and the left is begging for it at
this point because what they want is the
shock value right they want to push the
boundaries
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity hit the like button